cuáles son las diferencias que permiten
a washington y londres dejar de lado los
combustibles rusos hoy frente a por
ejemplo la unión europea y que tanto se
verá afectado el kremlin por esta
decisión para poner en contexto la
empresa se le retiró ya a todos sus
negocios del país y se disculpó por
comprar crudo después de la invasión
buenas tardes gracias por la oportunidad
realmente son decisiones soberanas las
que han tomado estas administraciones
sin embargo debo aclarar que de los
11.3 millones de barriles diarios que
produce rusia 10 millones de barriles
diarios van al exterior en venta de
petróleo crudo y de esos vienen a los
eeuu
672 mil barriles entre petróleo crudo y
derivados que llamamos derivados son más
condensados gas civil oil gas oil
etcétera entonces
ya la agencia internacional de energía
dijo que varios países se han
comprometido a poner en el mercado parte
de sus reservas para compensar esta
parte de pérdida de la exportación rusa
y sin embargo los países de opep de los
cuales prácticamente muchos no están
cumpliendo con las cuotas requeridas
están un poco tambaleante
a colocar más producción de petróleo
crudo en el mercado
entre tanto francia usted es venezolana
por eso le quiero preguntar qué
impresión le genera el acercamiento
entre eeuu y el chavismo ante rusia como
un enemigo mayor cree usted que dará a
washington el brazo a torcer a cambio de
petróleo a un gobierno que no reconoce y
que mantiene sancionado
en este caso debo decir que es decisión
soberana de la administración va a ir en
tratar de buscar todos los medios de de
digamos controlar la parte rusa
venezuela está llena de rusos y de
iraníes los rusos tienen armas y se debe
evitar una situación como la de cuando
la presidente kennedy de aquella
situación con cuba que estaban poniendo
la unión soviética
exactamente de las armas directo contra
eeuu en cuanto a maduro y obviamente si
hablaron seguro se vivieron elecciones
libre seguro que pidieron liberación de
los más de 300 presos políticos seguro
que pidieron que ellos deberían liberar
y tratar de ver cómo
liberan a los estudiantes que los tienen
torturados y también
venezolanos en capacidad en ninguna
manera de suministrar de estos 607 670
mil barriles a los eeuu canadá está allí
méxico está allí e inclusive creo que
colombia también puede aportar la
industria petrolera en venezuela está
totalmente destruida robada asaltadas
masacradas